all right amber were you from sacramento
calif i sec romero and tell me what your
family had both your parents growing up
no i grew up with my grandparents I was
raised by my grandmother my auntie and
my uncle where was it where was mama
daddy
my mom she grew up on the streets she
got into drugs I like date at night no
that's the first time she yeah and she
hasn't been right since and I'm
surprised she had kids but she got us to
me my grandma raised us and my while
she's being on the streets still on the
streets to this day and dad I really
don't know too much of my dad I mean I
know of his family but him himself I
don't know too much I just know he's was
drug addict like my mom oh really
grew up on the streets so you go
so you left home yep your is your
grandparents you were staying with and
you left them at what point it was like
13 when I start running in and out of
homes started living my grandma when I
was like four maybe I think that's what
my sister told me and you started at
what age working the streets 13 13
so how much what kind of money will you
make in tonight doing this today a whole
day and night at least twelve thirteen
hundred that's just walking yeah but I
mean I don't enjoy it but I just fell
into it yeah let's start teen walking
through the mall being fast met a guy
he took my virginity and told me look
you get on this corner and you're gonna
bust the stake and you're telling this I
don't know I just I didn't like the fact
that I would I had to do for it but I
don't know what as I grew older and
prone to like every day waking up I had
to do this I had to make this money I
had to get this guy it's just it just
got stuck into my program like I have to
do so was he functioning as a pimp for
you yeah and did you how much of the
money did you get him all of it all of
it as a pimp you can't get happy give
him long so I didn't like that either
cuz it's like it's my body I'm doing
this you know like why do I do I gotta
you know I don't know but I was young
and I was being fast and I didn't know
what I was getting myself into and then
when I got into it and didn't I just got
stuck have you been arrested fair plenty
of time I'm sorry millions of times oh
really
yeah I actually just got out of jail
from out here on Figueroa Undercovers
I'm fighting a prostitution case with
them they got me on probation it's just
ridiculous
do you have children of your own I do
have a six-year-old hey Cheryl who's
raising him or her it's a her I don't
know
my grandma is recently kind of lost her
but I'm trying to get her back and it's
kinda hard talking about that like I
don't want to start crying but you know
she's everything to me so I'm trying my
best to get her back but I know like me
being in his life it's just not gonna be
as easy as a person working a job and
you know doing what they had to do to
get their kid you know me I'm just
working on the streets praying I did
sketch she's gonna come to me that's not
gonna work like that I had a choice to
go homeless or to provide for my family
and I chose to provide for my family and
sometimes you gotta make sacrifices in
this world as human beings we gotta
sacrifice ourselves or something so we
can survive so you had some bad
experiences with guys you picked up I'm
not gonna line this crazy you asked me
two nights ago
I live I was staying on 80th of Figueroa
and I got in a car with a guy I'm
Mexican he was cool he didn't do nothing
to me we parked some some random kid
from out here got in his car took my
money he forced me to do stuff that I
didn't want to do I mean he started
calling me dirty like I was a dirty
process he started trying to make me
feel bad and lower of a woman and I what
I was and is it it's already bad enough
that being in this life and doing what
I'm doing you don't feel as much of a
woman you got to make yourself you got
to put it in your head like I'm still
beautiful I'm still woman you got to
tell yourself because every day like
you're going to meet different men
you're having sex you dirty man like you
know you feel let it's you they're
already giving yourself up so it's like
when he came in there and did that and
just like took my whole dignity from me
I'll just and it literally happened two
nights ago so I don't know why I'm still
back out here and yet I'm still back out
did you get depressed sometimes with
this life a lot I found myself sitting
in my hotel rooms trying to myself
because my baby cuz I call her and she
like mommy just come home and I can't
I'm stuck you know and like you know
it's not like I want to it's like
literally I'm like control do you know
so I'm like in this life I feel like
it's the game controlling me to keep
doing it I don't feel like it's me or
nobody else but the game and the money
you know I want to get out but I'm 21 I
feel like it's too late did you finish
high school no I was pregnant at 14 so
and I was hoeing at 13 I was like
ditching school just to go I lie to my
grandparents okay I'm going to school
I'm by myself on a track somewhere
making some money you do who the father
of each other's the father my child he's
not around but yeah oh yes he kind of
disappeared because as I grew up and I
realized in this game I don't need a pen
you know you you don't need a pimp they
was lie to you and say but that's
because they want your money to take
home to their family you know and I grew
up realizing that now my baby daddy was
like okay well you don't want to pay me
you want to act funny and keep your own
money so bye you know but I have a
daughter now so I don't feel like you
know and I'm just like one of those
females are not gonna pay nobody no more
I've been controlled I've been under
guys you know like I just I can't so my
baby daddy was just like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
the baby okay
so [ __ ] you too bye you know do you uh
you're currently working without a pimp
right now honestly I have a boyfriend
and I give him off my cut but he's not
like a pen so he doesn't take my full
cut he don't control me when I go out
there you don't you know
I do have some I do have a boyfriend a
lot I have a boyfriend but I don't have
a pen
when you when you were a young girl did
you have like dreams of a different life
than this I always dreamed of being like
a real estate agent you know or apply to
tennis somewhere higher class like cute
professional normal white girl like I
grew up for blonde here I should oh I
feel like I should have been behind the
desk that's how I feel in life I should
be on the plane being a flight attendant
I should be flipping houses you know I
have a big mouth piece you know I could
be a lawyer like I really wanted to be a
real estate honestly it's it's sad how
many young women end up working the
streets I mean like did you see it where
you're at there's they're all over I
know a couple of girls out here that are
younger than me I'm talking like 16 15
and I preach them like it out it's not
it's not what girls it's not made for
everybody no it's not this game is not
made for everybody you got to be a
strong woman to survive this cuz I did
I've been pistol it I've been shot at
I've been raped up and kidnapped do this
whole life okay
how do you think this what has changed
you you've been doing it for quite
awhile I think honestly as a person it
made me strong because if I never
experienced the things that I
experienced is going through this life I
probably wouldn't be as strong as I am
today I think it made me are strong with
me because I could still wake up and
tell myself okay you got this you're
still a good mother you're still
beautiful with me you got this you know
what do you think about your upbringing
your childhood what do you think if
something was different might have led
you down a very different path than this
a mom and a dad that wasn't on drugs I
had two normal jobs you know was willing
to raise kids on a normal household and
just not like you know on drugs I think
that probably would that's a big one
stirring me to the right path because
they've been times where I had to go on
the corner to get rip money my mom blew
it all on drugs and I have two sisters
somebody has to feed them I had to be in
the way somebody had to
so you were kind of taking care of your
sisters as well and what were your
sisters today they're all in Sacramento
they got jobs now they're doing their
thing a little different path than you
way better path to me yeah way better
but that's what I raised them to do you
know I didn't want them to have to
suffer like me you know it's not it's
not okay to be out here it's not it's
scary any woman any working female would
tell you it's scary to be outside
jumping in different cars not knowing
when you're coming home you know scary
and they're using drugs at all
I do ecstasy I take ecstasy every day or
every other day to keep going because I
work all day and I work all night so I
need something to keep me active
otherwise I just be like I can't work
I'm tired and then all right I don't
have no money
I gotta pay for hotel rooms every day I
don't have my own place so so you'll
travel around from city to city
I'll to California from Sacramento all
the way from here to LA to Bakersfield
to everywhere
all right well ever thank you so much
for talking to me and good luck with
with your future I hope you get to see
her get back together with your kid yeah
I really do too
that's like the biggest goal in life
yeah she needs you thank you
you